There are, it seems, no depths of Star Wars
obscurity which John Favreau will not plumb,
no peak of nerd minutiae that he will not
summit.
From the practical purpose of an ice cream
maker in space to the return of "maclunkey,"
The Mandalorian has now spent two full seasons
sinking its teeth into some of the most pedantic
references available, met at every turn with
fan appreciation.
In the closing moments of the show's second
season finale, longtime fans got a big surprise
in the form of a return visit to the Star
Wars galaxy's most evocatively smelly-looking
den of scum and villainy: Jabba's Palace,
last seen in live action during the events
of Return of the Jedi.
For an all-too-brief moment, viewers got to
catch up with old friends like Background
Weequay, Enslaved Twi'lek Number 14, and,
best of all, Bib Fortuna, Jabba's sniveling
toady from Episode VI.
And the showrunners didn't stop there.
True to form, they included an even more obscure
reference in their post-credits sting for
The Book of Boba Fett.
Unlike some of their other callbacks, you
didn't even need to be an obsessive fan to
spot it — you just needed to have $2.99
back in 1983.
It all goes back to the original trilogy,
merchandising, and the fact that action figures,
which absolutely are not dolls, need to accessorize.
Star Wars action figures were especially well
regarded in the field of adding weird extra
bits of plastic to sweeten the deal for kids,
with each addition nearly tripling the odds
of losing part of your favorite toy to a vacuum
cleaner.
An especially popular accoutrement for any
given action figure was a vaguely stick-shaped
thing.
Admiral Ackbar had a stick thing for some
reason.
So did General Madine.
And Bib Fortuna?
Well, Bib Fortuna had the most stick-shaped
thing of all.
Yes, Kenner's original Return of the Jedi
tie-in Bib Fortuna action figure carried with
him a long, twisty staff — a weird detail,
considering that the character never had one
in the movie, but hey.
"Gross pale fleshy-headed criminal guy" is
a tough sell, and kids love walking sticks,
right?
Maybe.
This was the same staff that Favreau and company
gave to Bib in his brief appearance at the
end of The Mandalorian's second season finale.
With any luck, this won't be the last action
figure callback in the series, and next season
will feature the return of Luke Skywalker,
now with Collector Coin and Saber Slam Action
Attack.
Batteries sold separately, of course.
However, by this point, you're probably wondering
who this Bib Fortuna guy is, in the first
place.
Sure, he was in Jabba's palace, and you know
he's the guy with the bumpy tentacle head,
but every Star Wars character has a super-elaborate
backstory, don't they?
And maybe, somewhere in that backstory, there
might be an explanation for his staff?
Thankfully, the mighty Star Wars-loving aficionados
at Wookieepedia have foreseen this great question,
and are here to answer any and all questions
about who Bib Fortuna is, on a deeper level.
Unfortunately, it seems that the history of
his staff — in canon, that is — remains
unanswered, but thankfully, some details about
Bib Fortuna himself have been established.
He is a Twi'lek from the planet Ryloth, who
at some point rose to become the second-in-command
to Jabba the Hutt, Tatooine's infamous crime
lord.
As it happens, the rancor seen in Return of
the Jedi — you know, the one they try to
kill off Luke with — was previously a birthday
present that Bib Fortuna gave to his master,
which is, frankly, about as weird as birthday
presents get.
Earning this prestigious position was, for
the record, a tough battle.
His main competitor for the role, a guy named
Bidlo Kwerve, ended up being sacrificed to
the aforementioned rancor, and has thus only
been seen on film as a usefully-placed skull
in Return of the Jedi.
Dubious hiring practices aside, Bib Fortuna
worked alongside his master for decades, going
back all the way to at least The Phantom Menace.
Following Jabba's death, The Mandalorian shows
that he took great pleasure in gaining control
of his former boss' palace, slaves, and fortunes,
up until his rather unfortunate (for him)
encounter with Boba Fett.
Behind the scenes, Bib Fortuna has been played
by a few actors.
Scottish actor Michael Carter was the original,
and the character's subsequent appearances
in both The Phantom Menace and The Mandalorian
have seen Matthew Wood take the role.
Is he coming back?
Probably not.
As you saw in The Mandalorian, it seems that
Bib Fortuna has met his maker, and ascended
into whatever mysterious afterlife the Star
Wars universe possesses.
But hey, at least he got to finally hold that
cool action figure-style staff before kicking
the bucket, right?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.